let's check this out this is going to
blow your mind Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman that is officially DC
Comics Trinity on the right you see Thor
Iron Man and Captain America that is
officially Marvel's Trinity there might
be some misunderstandings about the
Unholy Trinity of the Book of Revelation
who are these Unholy Trinity
symbolically it's a dragon we know
there's not really a dragon but
symbolically there's a dragon there is
the Beast and we know according to
prophecy that a beast is a king or a
kingdom and the false prophet what does
a prophet do a prophet points people to
worship a certain individual so
according to DC Comics you see Trinity
Trinity Trinity you see Batman Superman
and Wonder Woman now Marvel they have
the same thing Thor Iron Man Captain
America you might already be connecting
the dots